mittweida doch keine bedeutenden tag
mein name ist super herzlich willkommen
hier heute zu einem neuen video
gestaltet oder ich hab mein bier denn
trends gewesen namen macinga challenge
wird bei den harten job holt hilfe die
funny movie or life die tech müssen
eigentlich inditex nicht in den himmel
auf das ein trend ist genauso ein video
nur dass es in die etl und auf einen tag
hat es halt einfach 20 millionen aufrufe
des leute ein paar klicks zu mona
weniger oder verrückt solche videos auf
jeden fall schon länger in amerika und
jugendhilfe dieser trend von spiderman
freundin elsa und server sowie drüber
geschafft und jetzt haben wir die dinge
anscheinend auch in den trends der
sänger wir uns gedacht wir reagieren da
einfach mal drauf und schauen uns das an
[Musik]
bekannt durch die macht geprägten welt
verknüpfen
die beute vom paycheck minuten meist
aufzeichnet und in den letzten 30 tagen
haben die 300 millionen views gemacht
sie weisen viel wie katainen wegen
tieferen sind nun ein und erklärt wo ihn
die senioren mit überlegt er entwickelt
den mund bedeuten macht gewinnen legt
und jetzt fährt er steht auf und hat
eine lieferung gemacht
[Musik]
wir können nicht dazu sagen das ist
bestimmt eine minute es ist nichts
passiert
das video läuft hätte ich gerade eine
minute und dafür gewesen warum
ausgerechnet einer endlos party
millionen user auf allen ebenen p1 in
kleinen mittleren der wind einfach von
wie auch die verehrt wegfährt hatten
genommen weil meine dinge noch mit
werten und den kameramann gesehen in der
50 ich kaufe weise können sich auch
kinder
er hat seine modelle einfach vergessen
dass er dort möglich treffen derzeit
eher integriert damit dass man ein
[Musik]
die ganze härte und warum warum warum er
fährt jetzt quasi zum teller store um
sich neuesten teil einem gold zu kaufen
[Musik]
nein ich war an seinem haus meter weiter
dieser ecke wo halpin zu behäbig und
ihren tellern werke aus dem bestand der
nicht voll auf kaufen
es gibt eine riesige art daher warum
diese videos doch ich glaube wir einfach
einkaufen süßigkeiten gehen ja
offensichtlich für kinder ausgerichtet
und alle kinder mit süßigkeiten und dann
so richtig spielen beim feiern alle ganz
genau
so viele kunden am besten gefällt
die müssen sie bereit
[Musik]
sollte ihr müsst euch vorstellen das
sind erwachsene männer die unter dem
kostüm stecken und das spielen und auf
einem einfachen grund weil so viele
views auf youtube hatte als kind auf
vielleicht sogar angst oder was glaube
ich also das denke ich die ganze zeit
wenn der enkel heike steht und die intel
verkauft
ein fucking pool warum so hartung
ich weiß gar nicht was man dazu sagen
würde dass man das kommentieren soll ihr
müsst euch diese ganze szenerie weil
einfach vorstellen dass wir für einander
entfernt fünf meter weiter dessen
riesiger dem teller ingo store er
überlegt euch ganz erschließt sich
danach irgendwie 20 jahren überlegen
dass er tatsächlich hotel and go und
dann überlegt er sich ganz schön nochmal
anders und hier sind wir gespannt wie es
weitergeht dass viele der kurzen
werbeunterbrechung
[Musik]
walter nein mit die leute nicht wollten
ersten challenge aufnehmen und jetzt
gucken wir uns so was an zehn millionen
user kommentare die konten bei dem
anderen auf platz eins
es gibt keine dorn intendant latentes
penndorf leute deinen titel werden aber
ten dorf als bestimmt fans auf
französisch also ein warum ist das
entweder auf dem postareal video ist das
bett das sind genau die gleichen typen
die abschlussfeier meinung somit steht
als profi sie haben auch eine millionen
user alter what the [ __ ] und die machen
gegenseitig wer oder in anderen videos
werden auch mit 311 millionen bis 3
millionen
was für eine scheiße warum erst jetzt in
deutschland leute bahro und kann mir das
jetzt in deutschland leute warten vor
irgendwie in deutschland ist die
komplette scheibe sondern machen
freunde machen sich unter berühmten ich
mache das aus der scheiße video
irgendwann roland wir können feststellen
dass jetzt keiner dann machen wir sogar
noch drauf dann ging es zum kaffee
wir schauen dass man das video im netz
unter anderem durch verliert und
weinbergen der öl- und jetzt ist er hier
anscheinend irgendwann verlängert
[Musik]
arbeiten tief ist dass der verein das
ist doch nicht war zu gefährlich oder
waffen dazu eine beschnittene scheint
user mit dem kanal display kann dies in
kraft
du musst wie kommt ein problem kriegen
damit oder vergeblich von youtube 300
millionen views wenig gemacht weil ich
glaube das wird jetzt ganz interessant
bin jetzt stellen die hände und jetzt
bin ich offen
und jetzt wow der entwickler einen
größeren werden darf denn gedacht ist
denn jetzt hin und her hin und etwas der
daten sei zwar objektiv und warum
interessiert joe cada alter was die
sache eine kranke abgefragte scheiße für
diese debatte gezielt amerika allem ein
opfer des flugzeug
du hast es nicht machen weitere probiert
mit aller kraft bei der tournee wartet
nicht zu toren geholfen und einkommen
ich die ganzen körper helfen ihren
komplett sogar mit den riesigen wellen
erfasst bewertet und eine weg da die
täter
ist doch nicht auch mal wieder gewinnen
wird
direkte handelt dazu ein einziges kind
im dorf schon das wird eine spannende
verfolgungsjagd bei der wenn wir die
flächen nicht mit einer verknappung auf
diese fucking polak zu räumen die davor
hingestellt und habe einfach für das
übelste haus polizei
die wohnen wahrscheinlich alle dort und
übelste kniffligen anzusagen
sie denken sich dann so eine scheiße
wenn ich bei dem ende gehen macht genau
gleich mehr entscheiden geht auch wieder
sinken kindern gehen weitere auf dem weg
ins ausland ist ihr geschäft
konferenz also dass es doch nicht deren
ernst waren sich 0 arbeit damit wir
leben einfach davon dass eine marke brot
sind weder meniskus ist groß
nutella und dann sah das was sie machen
wenn er jetzt einen stopp wurde er kennt
auch nicht ich habe jetzt schon gar
nicht vor
das heißt erwin kaufen er wird
wahrscheinlich gegen die heck gefahren
genau die fans die platte stellt eine
pyramide auf genau jetzt kommt der
jogger umgeschnitten nein
der joker ist wieder da jetzt jagt
weiter werden in so gerade mit einem
motorrad in abschnitten für die video
sagen ich muss nicht sagen das es
verdient denn trends das ist es wirklich
eine unfassbar eine hollywood-produktion
ende führen wird dass wir bewerten da
wartet ihr vom video meine damen und
herren wenn wir euch bei dinge
unterhalten konnten dass ich überhaupt
kein leichter und auch wenn machen ich
das mal nachstellen sollen hier findet
ihr die eigene wenn der leser braucht
ihr könnt ihm einen kanal kostenlos
abonnieren verfasste videos mehreren
noch mensch noch eingeblendet und hier
ein anderes video unter das jetzt vorbei
ist raus